Hey guys! So a few of you asked me to
make a video on the best shampoo and
conditioner for men. We all use shampoo a few times every day right and
conditioner but we don't realize just
how important the right shampoo and a
right conditioner is for our hair type
most guys think that good hair is all
about the right wax or pomade or
hairspray or style but great hair
actually starts in the shower using the
right shampoo and the right conditioner
to treat your hair. So in this video
we're gonna look at the best shampoo and
conditioner for all hair types so let's
get right into the video.
Yo guys!
If this is the first time that you're here on my channel, welcome. I'm Daniel,
consider subscribing and also clicking the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let's start with
the best shampoo and conditioner for men
with thin hair
first up is Brickell's daily
strengthening shampoo and also their
revitalizing conditioner. These two are
great for men of any age. It doesn't
matter how old you are because it works
great in really strengthening and making
your hair look fuller. Another good
option for men with thin hair is the
true volume thickening shampoo from Jack Black and they also have a good nourishing
hair and scalp conditioner that you can
use with it. Now their shampoo uses this
unique blend of ingredients that helps
your hair follicles to be healthier
which overall helps your hair to look
thicker and better. I'm not gonna go into
a lot of detail here because I want this
video to stay short and sweet but as
always I'll add it for in the video
description so you can go and check it
out. Now let's move on.
Now if you're
struggling with hair loss you're not alone.
There's around... well research says
that it's around 2 out of every 3 guys that
will start to lose their hair after the
mid-thirties. Which is a lot of people.
So you're not alone but there are
good products and supplements that you
can use that will really help you out as
always I'll add it for in the video
description but this video is only about
the shampoo and conditioner so first
shampoo that will help you with your
hair growth is biotin. Now this is
probably the best shampoo out there in
the market. Why? Well it's an
extra-strength B complex shampoo and it uses all natural
ingredients to promote hair growth and
it slows hair loss. Another good option
is the recovery shampoo and
conditioner from ultrax labs.
Now they contain a lot of good stuff but
most importantly they contain powerful
caffeine compounds which have been shown to reduce hair loss, helps hair growth
and blocks the effects of the testosterone
in the skin.
If you're struggling with dandruff the
best shampoo out there for you is Nizoral
They've been around for a very long
time they're a trusted brand and they're
very hard to beat. Why? Well the stuff
just works. They deliver on their promise.
One of the best tips I can give you
whenever you look at products or when you
want to buy products is don't focus so much on their advertising. I mean today's
advertising you can't trust it. Look at the
customer reviews. I will add it for you in
the video description so you can go ahead and check it out. Check out those
customer reviews of guys like you and me
that tried it out already. Now if you
want a good drugstore product you can
try dove two-in-one anti-dandruff yes
they are good and they will help. Now
let's move on
now if you struggle with dry and damaged
hair you can try out argan oil from Art
Naturals. Now the argan oil is very
popular and most people know that it helps
repair and restore damaged dry hair.
Another great option for dry and damaged
hair is American Crew daily moisturizing
shampoo and conditioner
So what are the best overall hair shampoo
and conditioner for men? We'll first up
Krieger and sohne. It's infused with
natural ingredients like tea tree oil
and peppermint which will also help you
with dry scalp and dandruff. It smells great
and in delivers on its promise. Another
good one is the every man-jack 2 in 1
for all hair types. Every man-jack has
high quality but affordable grooming
products made just for guys and they're
all natural 2 in 1 shampoo and
conditioner will leave your hair
stronger, softer and healthier.
Now just a last tip for you guys: Don't wash your hair every single day. Why?
Because if you do, then you're gonna strip your hair of all the natural oils and it's gonna leave
your hair to dry. So wash it only around
two to three times a week. That will keep
the natural oils in there, keep your hair
moisturized and looking healthy and good
If you liked the video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and I'll see you in the
next video cheers guys